how bad is it if you have a really high  amount of alcohol in your skincare  products well there have been lots of  studies done in hand sanitizers which  have 60 to 80 alcohol they found that  even with these really high  concentrations applied 20 to 100 times a  day to forearm skin there wasn't any  extra inflammation or skin barrier  disruption the only significant effect  was dehydration and this could be  reversed by adding moisturizing  ingredients like glycerin and fatty  alcohols now face skin is thinner than  forearm skin but skin care products only  have five to ten percent alcohol you  apply the maximum five times a day and  they have moisturizing ingredients in  them so inflammation and skin barrier  disruption are pretty unlikely  dehydration could happen but it depends  on the formula